- How are you?
- I'm good, thank you.
- [Kelly] You're good?
- How are you?
- I know there was like, a health scare.
You're good though, right?
- Um, yes.
There was a health scare,
I'm totally okay now.
I'm doing much better.
I'm doing completely fine.
- And it was something random, right?
That you'd never heard of.
I think that's, it's not cool
that it's happening to you,
but I think that it's cool
that you're putting a spotlight on it
for people that maybe didn't
have the spotlight on it.
- Yeah, it was something that,
honestly, I was born with.
I was born with a heart
defect, it's called a PFO.
I won't try to butcher the
actual name of it, but.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Basically I was born
with a hole in my heart
and it never closed.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And I didn't know.
Apparently it's very, very common.
A lot of people have
it and they don't know.
Um, and it was just kind of like
this perfect storm of
things that led to me
having a small blood clot,
which was really scary and really crazy.
And I had something called a TIA,
which is like a mini stroke.
- Geez.
- [Hailey] Yeah.
- And you're so young, but it's like,
it's horrible that it happened to you,
but it's nice that you're
putting awareness on it
just for people.
- [Hailey] Yeah.
- 'Cause can you get like a
scan to check that, to see?
- Um, you-
- 'Cause I've had a heart scan,
I don't know if they could tell me
if there was a hole in it.
- You can, there's a
special type of testing
you can do for it.
And I never knew any of this before.
I thought I was 25 and healthy.
- Well you're like, young.
Like why? Yeah, like
I wouldn't have, yeah.
- I had no idea,
but it's been a big learning experience.
I, you know, I made a video about it,
I talked about everything,
and hopefully it can help someone
going through the same thing, so.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
And just something to be aware of
'cause I'd never heard of that.
- Yeah.